India is making industry trade and the
education sector the mainstays of its
economy 2010 was an historic year for
Indian children it was the year that the
right of children to free and compulsory
education act came into force today
ninety-six percent of students who
attend elementary school in India will
get a school leaving certificate but in
a country were roughly half the
population lives below the poverty line
the biggest impediment to education
remains child labour Guatemala is often
described as the land of eternal spring
the long-running civil war that ended in
1996 claimed hundreds of thousands of
lives in Guatemala forty percent of the
population is under 14 in rural areas
many children leave school early even so
eighty-six percent of children finish
elementary school in sub-saharan Africa
Ghana is leading the way when it comes
to education in 2005 the government
abolished all primary school fees and
now subsidizes students food and clothes
Ghana is on track to become the first
country in Africa to cut poverty in half
by 2015
ghana is home to 17,000 state schools
that's the highest number of any african
country by 2015 the government hopes
that every child will be able to finish
school
you